she's part of the fabric of Britain
Malone's previous eating she's been head
of state longer than most people can
remember written without her at the
traditional king and queen pub in
London's Fitzrovia the barkeeper of this
pro Royals establishment can't imagine
it to me she's always been the Queen as
well because I'm very well kalahari
years is that's 67 years isn't it her
reputation here is flawless vital to the
country an icon figure and someone up
you know we all looked up to as a nation
without the Queen where would we be I
think yeah how about London's East End
home to many immigrants from the
Commonwealth our people here getting
prepared for the momentous occasion we
wanted to find out so it's the Queen's
birthday did you know about that yes I
did yes we all do around here bodies
mentioning here talking about it it's a
very big thing here in London she's a
great person and I'm saying now I really
I really love her you know so yeah she's
doing everything at zalman brothers
cash-and-carry shop there's already a
party atmosphere one of the assistants
is planning a banquet yeah 19 birthday
mrs. Cohen I'm cooking now you take
either party all people eating after
enjoy yeah we had to look long and hard
for someone who isn't getting into the
Royal revelry nothing against her
personally but this customer says it's
time for the monarchy to go I do kind of
wish that we as a country would sort of
grow up and get with the modern world
and like Alexa president
not at all say most British people god
bless the Queen's everybody there to you
win yeah I Majesty the Queen long may
she reign and that's what she probably
will do